ein algorithmus von google schlägt den
besten golfspieler der welt vier zu eins
in dota 2 spielt die ki von opel besser
als das beste menschliche team und sogar
das laufen können simulierte roboter
ganz von alleine lernen das alles sind
beispiele von rhi enforcement learning
vielleicht der form von beschieden
learning die aktuell am meisten
aufmerksamkeit hype und schlagzeilen
bekommt und es ist ja auch eine super
faszinierende form der künstlichen
intelligenz algorithmen die lernen wie
wir menschen es tun durch belohnung
bestrafung und eine menge wiederholung
aber wie genau funktioniert das
eigentlich welche vor und nachteile hat
wie enforcement learning gegenüber
anderen maschinen learning methoden und
können auch roboter in der echten welt
so lernen genau das will ich heute in
diesem video herausfinden und ich kann
schon mal so viel verraten es wird
ziemlich krass
[Musik]
wow das ist jetzt schon die vierte und
damit leider letzte folge unserer
videoserie über kg in zusammenarbeit mit
dem max planck institut für intelligente
systeme die ersten drei folgen findet
ihr hier in der playlist und es lohnt
sich wirklich die alle noch mal zu
gucken um einen guten überblick über das
thema ihn zu bekommen sowohl über die
möglichkeiten als auch über die
fallstricke jetzt geht es aber um wie
enforcement learning natürlich wieder
zusammen mit annika buchholz die sich
als forschungs koordinatoren in tübingen
mit verschiedenen aspekten des
maschinellen lernens beschäftigt wie
schon vor dem intro angedeutet habe ist
wie in fonds mit learning vom
lernverhalten von uns inspiriert von
lebewesen hunger und schmerz geben uns
zum beispiel negative anreize etwas
leckeres zu essen wiederum ist eine
belohnung besonders anschaulich kann man
das bei babys und kindern beobachten
wenn ein neugeborenes baby auf die welt
kommt dann werde das am anfang nur so
mit den awo mit den beinen und sieht
sehr zufällig aus und dann kam wirklich
sehen dass das mit der zeit immer
gezielt da wird das irgendwie das kind
dann probiert und objekt an zu stutzen
und irgendwann lernt das zugreifen
dann hättest du hin zu klopfen und zu
schütteln und nimmt es in den mund und
so begreift dann dieses kind stück für
stück objekte und seine umwelt diese art
des lernens scheinen wir menschen ein
leben lang beizubehalten und das ist
auch die grundidee von rain faustmann
kleining okay man versucht hier also die
lernmethoden der natur nachzubilden was
seit millionen von jahren für uns gut
funktioniert lässt sich ja bestimmt auch
auf maschinen übertragen neben super
weist und an super weist learning ist
wie enforcement learning das dritte
grundkonzept des maschinellen lernens
hier gibt es keine klassischen input
output daten paare stattdessen werden
daten durch die interaktion mit der
umwelt gesammelt ganz frei und explora
tief also erkunden aber wie genau
funktioniert dass das lernen objekt zum
beispiel ein roboter wird typischerweise
als agent bezeichnen dieser agent
bekommt ein ziel vorgegeben aber keine
konkreten anweisungen wie er dieses ziel
erreichen kann stattdessen lernt der
durch wechselwirkung mit seiner umwelt
und so lernte eine strategie mit der das
ziel erreichen kann und zwar ganz
alleine am besten veranschaulichen wir
das mal an einem beispiel sagen wir wir
wollen unserem algorithmus beibringen
ein spiel zu spielen für go gibt es ein
paar zu viele spiel zustände deswegen
haben wir uns für einen absoluten
klassiker aus unserer kindheit
entschieden und zwar vier gewinnt für
jeden zustand im spiel gibt es eine
bewertungsfunktion die schätzt was von
hier aus der bestmögliche ausgang des
spiels sein könnte aus dieser bewertung
erschließt sich dann eine erwartbare
belohnung je wahrscheinlicher ein sieg
mit diesem spiel zustand ist desto
größer ist die belohnung das macht
typischerweise ein neuronales netzwerk
und am anfang ist das noch komplett
zufällig erst mit der zeit lernt es die
zustände besser zu bewerten das netzwerk
spuckt dann eine zahl zwischen null und
eins aus die aussichtsreicher der
spielstand desto höher ist die zahl und
damit kann jetzt jeder einzelne mögliche
spielzug bewertet werden wie nahe bringt
mich zum beispiel dass hier meinem ziel
und das hier das ziel ist in diesem fall
natürlich vier von der eigenen farbe in
eine reihe zu bekommen ihr kennst jetzt
wäre es natürlich offensichtlich einfach
immer die aktion zu wählen die die
höchste bewertung hat klar aber hier
müssen wir aufpassen denn wir wollen ja
dass unser algorithmus auch dazu lernt
deswegen gibt es immer auch eine
erkundungs komponente auf zufalls basis
der agent soll dinge ausprobieren und
herumexperimentieren diese zufalls
komponente ermöglicht die erkundung der
umgebung und damit das finden von neuen
strategien aber das ist ein balance akt
zu viele experimente und es fehlte die
zielstrebigkeit der algorithmus gewinnt
nicht immer nur das erlangte wissen
nutzen und nach der höchsten bewertung
zu gehen sorgt wiederum dafür dass sich
der algorithmus nicht weiterentwickelt
er verbessert seine strategie nur noch
wenig da er seine umgebung nicht groß
erkunden kann am ende des spiels werden
dann alle getätigten spielzüge
rückblickend analysiert und bewertet das
neuronale netz wird trainiert und die
bewertungsfunktion wird stück für stück
besser und dann kann der ganze spaß auch
schon wieder von vorne losgehen in
manchen situationen wie zum beispiel bei
spielen lässt man den computer hingegen
sich selber antreten das kann man zum
beispiel machen indem man einfach zwei
agenten gegeneinander spielen lässt und
das ist wie enforcement learning ganz
ganz ganz grob zusammengefasst es
ermöglicht das lernen von strategischem
verhalten in komplexen umgebungen wie zb
spielen aber auch in der echten welt zum
beispiel beim greifen eines unbekannten
objekt das coole ist dass die daten
selbstständig und explorative gesammelt
werden und dass der algorithmus darauf
trainiert wird irgendeine strategie zu
finden nicht zwangsläufig die beste das
vereinfacht das problem und sorgt dafür
dass manchmal extrem kreative lösungen
gefunden werden und genau da
unterscheidet sich reinforced und
learning von super weist und an super
weiß learning in diesen beiden anderen
methoden geben wie dem algorithmus die
daten gelabelt oder nicht geregelt aber
beim reinforced mit learning muss sich
der algorithmus die daten selber
beschaffen
[Musik]
in der welt der simulationen können wir
schon einige sehr spannende dinge mit
wie in fonds mit learning anstellen aber
die wahre herausforderung könnte man
argumentieren liegt in der echten welt
aktuell werden die allermeisten roboter
mithilfe von kontroll theorie
programmiert und gesteuert dh dass ein
computerprogramm fest ein programmierte
befehle ausführt es kennt zum beispiel
die genauen abmaße des eigenen körpers
und weiß exakt wo sich die hand befinden
wird wenn sich ein bestimmtes gelenk am
abend für eine bestimmte zeit bewegt
jeder aktion wird genau berechnet es
klingt im ersten moment natürlich
sinnvoll aber bei uns menschen
funktioniert das ja anders wir wissen
nicht auf den millimeter genau wie lange
unser arm ist oder wo der sich in
relation zu einem objekt befindet
stattdessen haben wir alle mit der zeit
eine gewisse intuition dafür entwickelt
wie wir etwas greifen können nämlich als
babys perry enforcement learning wenn
man so will und ohne jetzt zu sehr an
geben zu wollen aber ich würde behaupten
dass wir menschen besser darin sind
dinge zu greifen als die meisten roboter
deswegen versucht man reinforced und
learning jetzt auch in der robotik
einzusetzen und zwar unter anderem am
max planck institut für intelligente
systeme in tübingen und das ist wirklich
die cutting edge der ki forschung ich
konnte mich dort mit stefan bauer
unterhalten er war bis vor kurzem
forschungsgruppenleiter am mpi für
intelligente systeme und hat inzwischen
eine professur an der kth stockholm
und er hat sich das konzept für die tri
finger plattform ausgedacht und diese
auch mit entwickelt die drei finger
plattform ist dem schema in der
menschlichen hand nachempfunden das
heißt wir haben drei finger mit jeweils
drei freiheitsgraden die dann
schematisch eine objekte manipulieren
sollen und mit objekte hochheben können
und damit lernen sollen mit objekten
umzugehen und physikalische konzepte wie
zum beispiel reibung gravitation eine
ähnliche konzepte zu lernen um dann
diese objekte auch komplex zu
manipulieren beispielsweise eine
bestimmte orientierung zu bringen oder
hoch zu gehen das ziel ist tatsächlich
roboter zu entwickeln die über bestimmte
in umgebungen auch um objekte
generalisieren können das heißt momentan
trainieren wir mit diesem würfel
allerdings ist in der zukunft geplant
dass wir ein beliebiges objekt in die
arena des roboters leben können und dann
lernt er das objekt erst kennen zu
lernen und danach zu manipulieren so
dass wenn wir ihm sagen bringen sie eine
bestimmte orientierung es tatsächlich
schafft und das für neue objekte zu
schaffen die der roboter noch nie
gesehen hat dass tatsächlich eine große
schwierigkeit und das ist auch der grund
warum das ganze nicht mit kontroll
theorie gemacht werden kann da müsste
man vorher wissen welche eigenschaften
ein objekt hat wie groß es ist wie
schwer es ist et cetera aber wenn ich
wirklich jedes beliebige objekt
hochheben können will dann brauche ich
ruhe in forst und hörning wie wir vorhin
gelernt haben gibt es beim medienfonds
mit lernen ja darum dass agent seine
umgebung erkundet mit ihr interagiert
und daraus feedback bekommt und genau
deswegen habe ich mich gefragt wie das
bei der tri finger plattform eigentlich
passiert irgendwo zu werden tatsächlich
von den algorithmen genutzt und es sind
alle inputs und dazu gehören die
sensoren die an den fingerkuppen sind
die den druck und zum beispiel den
kontakt mit dem objekt wieder geben als
auf die motoren die zum beispiel in
bestimmten strom messen und in
bestimmten stärke mitnehmen darauf ob
das objekt berührt als auch die kameras
die die szene widerspiegeln aus allen
drei richtungen und dann hat dieser
inputs lernt der algorithmus dann zum
beispiel wo das objekt ist und wo das
ziel ist und welche aktionen dabei
helfen das ziel zu erreichen ok könnte
man jetzt sagen würfel hochheben kann
ich auch was ist denn jetzt daran
wirklich so schwierig die ersten
ergebnisse für die algorithmen sind
tatsächlich auf den ersten blick relativ
trivial das heißt wir trainieren die
algorithmen dass sie zum beispiel einen
objekt erreichen das heißt die
fingerspitze berührten bestimmten punkt
oder wir trainieren die algorithmen
darauf dass sie das objekten bestimmte
neue situation bewegen das heißt sie
schieben das objekt eine bestimmte
konstellation und das klingt für uns
jetzt was menschen aus ausgebildete
menschen relativ trivial und einfach
allerdings wenn wir schon zurückgehen
und die vergangenheit ein bisschen wie
wir selber gelernt haben als wir kinder
waren oder kleinkinder waren dann
wussten wir auch nicht was ein objekt
dass wir wussten diese physikalischen
konzepte nicht was zum beispiel reibung
ist mich stark ich jetzt ein objekt mit
einer rauen oberfläche schieben kann
oder dass gravitation ist und all diese
konzepte die wir jetzt alle schon
verinnerlicht haben die muss der
algorithmus erstmal lernen und zwar ohne
irgendetwas zu wissen der algorithmus
lernt tatsächlich ohne jegliche
vorkenntnisse und das dauert relativ
lange das heißt allein schon um das
objekt zu erreichen sind beispielsweise
700 situationen von dem algorithmus
notwendig die jeweils eine sekunde
dauern
700 versuche nur um ein objekt zu
berühren das ist echt eine menge arbeit
deswegen habe ich mich gefragt warum
bewegung in der echten welt so viel
schwieriger zu lernen ist wenn doch
gleichzeitig computerspiele und auch gut
zum beispiel schon gemeistert wurden und
auch das hat mir stefan netterweise
erklären das liegt auch daran dass man
sehr viele weniger echte roboter in
gewisser weise zur verfügung hat auch
den man trainieren kann zu ihren
tübingen haben wir mittlerweile acht
plattformen war schon relativ große
skepsis während man mit diesem video
spielen einfach in der simulation das
ganze auf supercomputern verbreiten kann
und so mehr oder weniger mehrere spiele
gleichzeitig trainieren kann kann man in
der echten welt maximal eben auf diesen
echten plattform die die algorithmen
trainieren und das rennen läuft dann nur
in echtzeit ab das heißt die roboter
können sich zwar eventuell sehr schnell
bewegen allerdings kann man eine
simulation beispielsweise spiele 1000
mal pro sekunde simulieren um so sehr
viel mehr trainingsdaten zur verfügung
haben in der echten welt ist das anders
hier hatte algorithmus nur bilder die
von der kamera kommen und er erfährt zum
beispiel nicht was sein objektes wo das
objekt ist und muss diese vorgaben erst
lernen vor dem hintergrund fand ich es
auch sehr beeindruckend was das team
schon alles geschafft hat inzwischen
können die algorithmen mit den drei
fingern würfel hochheben stapeln und in
der hand neu orientieren und das ist wie
gesagt erst der anfang die basis wurde
gelegt und viele daten gesammelt bald
will das team mit unbekannten objekten
experimentieren stellt sich natürlich
die eine frage die man sich immer stellt
wenn man sowas hört wird es irgendwann
selbst lernende menschenähnliche roboter
geben die einfach so auf der straße
rumlaufen es ist tatsächlich eine sehr
gute frage wann wir erster roboter haben
die wie menschen funktionieren und auch
autonom vollkommen autonom lernen können
das ganze wird leider noch etwas dauern
das ist jetzt praktisch ein erster
ansatz und das ist eine sehr
kontrollierte umgebung das heißt wir
haben hier im prinzip ein käfig um den
lernten algorithmus umgebaut um
bestimmte vorsichtsmaßnahmen auch ein zu
finden wenn wir es tatsächlich einen
roboter bauen würden nach vorbild des
menschen dann hätte er auch ähnlich wie
in kraft wie der mensch und das wäre
instanzen sehr gefährlich und auch
eventuelle zerstörerisch es gibt erste
versuche roboter nach menschen
aufzubauen beispielsweise von boston
dynamics allerdings laufen diese roboter
typischerweise nicht mit leeren
algorithmen sondern eher mit kontroll
theoretischen algorithmen okay ich bin
ganz ehrlich als ich das gehört habe war
ich eher beruhigt als enttäuscht es ist
nämlich unglaublich beeindruckend woran
hier geforscht wird die ersten schritte
scheinen noch banal zu sein aber wenn
etwas mit hilfe von rui enforcement
learning erstmal auf eine allgemeiner
art verstanden wurde dann steht einem
nicht mehr viel im wege genauso wie wir
objekte hochheben und manipulieren
können die wir noch nie in der hand
hatten könnte das dann auch ein roboter
und das ist pure science-fiction an der
hege forscht wird und ich habe euch noch
gar nicht von solo aid dem springenden
vierbeiner erzählt auch hier wird
bereits wieder in fonds mit learning
eingesetzt und das team will den roboter
bald so weiterentwickeln dass er immer
selbstständiger bewegungen wie laufen
oder springen lernen kann das hier ist
wie gesagt das vierte und damit leider
schon letzte video unserer ki serie in
den folgen davor ging es um generative
modelle die frage ob künstliche
intelligenz wirklich intelligent ist und
warum die menschen diskriminiert und wie
wir das verhindern können alles drei
sehr sehr spannende themen und wichtige
themen also schaut euch die folgen gerne
an falls sie das noch nicht eh schon
getan habt wenn jetzt noch fragen zum
thema kali- und vor allem zum thema
reinforced learning habt dann schreibt
uns die sich gerne unten in die
kommentare und annika und ich werden uns
mühe geben sie alle zu beantworten und
an dieser stelle möchte ich mich noch
ein letztes mal ganz ganz herzlich bei
annika für die konzeptionierung und die
gemeinsame ausarbeitung dieser serie
hier bedanken dankeschön es hat mir sehr
viel spaß gemacht und wie immer vielen
dank auch an euch fürs zuschauern und
bis zum nächsten mal bleibt neugierig
neuester trick